le dialogue suppose que chaque parti
puisse aller jusqu'au bout de son droit
ce qui pour les
palestinien comme pour les autres peut
le moment venu signifier un état je n'ai
pas plus qu'un autre à tranché qui
représente ce peuple et qui ne le
représente
pas comment
l'OLP par exemple qui parle au nom des
combattants peut-elle espérer s'asseoir
à la table des négociations tant qu'elle
dénira le principal et le droit
d'exister et les moyens de sa sécurité à
Israël le dialogue suppose la
reconnaissance préalable et mutuelle du
droit de l'autre à l'existence le
renoncement préalable mutuel à la guerre
directe ou indirecte est en entendu que
chacun retrouvera sa liberté d'agir en
cas d'échec